good morning Millennials welcome to
toast la the westcoast toast first
episode it's Monday for us but when
you're listening to this it's gonna be
Tuesday we hope you had a great Monday
great weekend I hope you either
celebrated or didn't celebrate Columbus
days it's like a very triggering holiday
um so like I know a lot of people like
we're out of school and like some people
were not I don't know like where society
has fallen on Columbus Day but I just
want to be in the right side of history
so I'm thinking no except that
technically like we celebrated Columbus
Day because we enjoy the show but thank
God we took it off because I was struck
down oh my god my food poisoning in this
town it's like la knew I was too excited
to be here and they were like [ __ ] calm
down we got here at 6:45 p.m. and like
at nine o'clock we were like hitting the
ground running like dressed for a movie
premiere going out to a dinner like
meeting all of our West Coast friends
and Jackie was taken down by a salmon
something a salmon carpaccio I honestly
don't know what it was we all kind of
shared plates there were a few things I
more of than others and when I woke up I
just assumed I was hungover cuz I was
having hungover symptom but like like
she drank like a few glasses of wine
really not enough wine to warrant
vomiting three times before I fell
asleep vomiting all through the morning
dry heaving I know this is disgusting
but then I got an IV from the IV doc
that saved my life but actually crazy to
watch when she started the IV like
homegirl could not pick her head up and
by the end like she wasn't gagging and
she was just sitting up like normally so
after the IV I did not throw up again
like I didn't feel great but I felt like
how you probably should when you're
hungover right food poisoning but it was
so upsetting I didn't get to go to the
DJ tea that was wedding I heard rave
reviews it was so crazy like I don't
think I've ever played a theater that
was as like important do you know any
man oh you think like he was very
historic it was beautiful you know
you're like legit when the seats in your
theater or red velvet you know it was
Velveteen vibes and it was a great show
I got to do a fun entertainment tonight
like backstage thing which I'm really
excited to see do you know when it airs
no I was talking so like fast and
annoying like people are gonna see it
and they're either gonna like love me or
[ __ ] hey me you know yeah which I
highlight the fastest Huff um and it was
a great show lots of toasty vibes out
here on the west coast it was good and I
was like really nervous like backstage
like usually I I could walk in front of
a peep like a crowd of
in or 5,000 and I don't care but
something about like the energy and like
la it's like the town that entertained I
mean a straight town full of bigwigs and
it's crazy like we'll go to a restaurant
and okay probably everyone's a nobody
but there's a chance there it says
somebody in the room and that just like
makes you want to be on your better game
and I knew that like my managers and
everyone was Aaron I know they probably
invited like important people and I was
just like so nervous
and I was sweating so much like my hair
was soaking wet it looks like at when I
got off stage I look like I just got out
of the shower like I put my hair in a
bun and it was soaking wet it was
discussing not to be really too graphic
but it was really good really fun I had
a great time and we're here in LA and
then Friday I head to San Diego and
Sunday we have two shows in San
Francisco the San Francisco ones I think
are both sold out but there's still a
few tickets left to San Diego ticket
available a car loan job back home you
know I had to get them in there I'm
sorry back to your regularly scheduled
programming back to your regularly
scheduled la programming we are so la in
this studio right now so l is so crazy
shout out to Nick vile for letting us
you know like use his studio because
it's like out here in LA it's just like
no-man's land like you need to get
something done like where do you go ya
know it's really all about who you know
Nick Amaro what's crazy is I'm learning
about LA like if I want to be in a movie
or hallmark movie like all I have to do
is really know someone who like makes
those bigwig decisions yeah it's never
about like who's the most talented now
it's always about like who do you know
whose couch did you sit it's all about
who you know it's networking which is my
worst skill or because it's my biggest
weakness exactly in huh that's a great
answer for an interview like for a job
when they like what's your biggest
weakness and people are like I'm too
prepared know people were like I'm too
detail-oriented I'm too good at my job I
hate people like that I have you care
too much I actually have a great answer
go ahead see you or that okay ask me
let's do like a mock interview hi
Claudia hi Claudia I'll show you
attorney at law Wow thank you for coming
in today
you know thank you so much for having me
it's really an honor to be here so why
do you want this job
well I don't I need money but I need
money yeah okay and as a worker bee what
are your biggest strengths and what are
your weaknesses you know I think my
biggest strengths are my abilities to
work really well on a team you know I
find that I just really work well off
you know bouncing ideas off of others
but you know my biggest weakness is
something I've really struggled with and
it may be something that you've actually
noticed talking over me I have a very
difficult time
making eye contact and I know that it
definitely is not a great look and it's
something I'm really working on I'm sure
you've noticed it as we're sitting here
it's just it's something that that I
can't really grasp you know that's not
like a bad weakness but there's
something so creepy about it it's like I
think it's I grant make eye contact
because I'm about to murder you know I
think it's such a great answer because
like there's nothing wrong with me like
I could still do my job you know what I
mean like when people like what's your
biggest weakness I'm dumb like I'm not
gonna hire you like it doesn't affect
how they see me but it's also not like
I'm too detail-oriented you know it's
not a couple should answer like I
actually do really struggle with making
eye contact with people who I'm like not
comfortable with yeah so I think was
actually start looking around like oh I
need to grab a drink because I can't
never totally well that's why we're
failing out here in LA you seen the hors
d'oeuvres yeah it's like it's so Kosh
always looking for a cater waitress
event catered yeah whose caterer
can I get cater waiter so here's
business as usual we are going to
deliver the fast five stories that you
need to know before you wake up and take
a bite out of your morning toast and we
are going to be graced by a very
prestigious set of guests this week and
today is no exception we have Gary
Jannetty and Brad Goreski power couple
dynamic duo truly like both individually
would have loved to have them as as
guests together like I can't believe
we're being bestowed this prestigious
honor I really don't you press a lot
together Gary has a new book coming out
I got it I started to read it it's
hilarious I'm sad to say everything we
look more cute looks for Brad today but
we did kill me they don't want him to
judge us and think we're going on an
unfashionable podcast no and he's not
gonna walk in here see our outfits yeah
no no like he's gonna be like Carrie
what did you bring me to know I put on
like a Fupa protecting ensemble today
specifically for Brad I put on the one
t-shirt that I got at the wasteland that
is Bloomingdale's this past week and you
know what it's really changing my game
and I don't know if you can see my shoes
I just want to give a shout out to my
shoes they're real cuz um they're so
[ __ ] cute and I wanted them for so
long and then like three seasons later I
was able to afford them and I love them
and this section my first time wearing
them so I think they're gonna be my big
LA shoe yeah you know because it says
like oh I mean business but a little bit
of pleasure but like a little pube -
totally alright so let's dive in before
we dive in before we dive in is there
something you want
at the class you know what it's like
been bothering me like I have to get you
guys are looking like cutting your shits
look so big today who's gonna say jugs
and then in no other um people are
probably in the clutter you like your
jugs look so big today it's actually
because I have something I've been
meaning to get off my chest
okay please share today's episode is
brought to you by legacy box one of our
favorite sponsors and truly one of the
most genius ideas like I everyday I want
to think to myself like how did I not
come up with legacy box people know it's
sure okay I have to pull my skirt down
Oh what we showing that this is not that
men showing cellulite if you've been
seeing my cellulite this time she's
nodding I have cellulite so legacy box
is an amazing company that turns your
old home videos cassettes like old ass
[ __ ] things that you don't know what
to do with but like has important you
know memories on they take care of all
of it basically you send your legacy box
filled with old home movies and pictures
they'll do the rest professionally
digitizing your moments onto a thumb
drive digital download or DVD they have
easy to follow instructions and safety
bar codes included for every item you
receive all your original recorded
moments back along with a perfectly
preserved digital copy you get
personalized updates at every step
receive up to 12 personalized email
updates legacy box is the world's
largest most trust and digitizer of home
movies and photos over 450,000 families
have trusted legacy box over a decade of
experience and all the work is done by
hand right here in the USA if you have
ever tried to get like a moment of yours
off of VCR and like had to go to Best
Buy and like buy this adapter that
doesn't work and then like literally
just want to blow your reins out good
luck this product is for you it's
actually really genius and I can't
believe I don't think of it there's
never been a better time to digitally
preserve your memories Vegas visit
legacy box calm today to get started
plus for a limited time they're offering
our listeners an exclusive discount go
to legacy box calm / toast to get 40%
off your first order go to legacy
box.com / toast and you'll be able to
save 40% off today get started
preserving your past
sign on like get to know your old self
and realize that you haven't changed
that much no that's my favorite thing
about watching old home movies it's like
you're the same on the same this
snatchler is the same snatching
everything up and olivia is the same in
charge it actually really depends i'm
like you're either look back and you're
like dad I'm the same person or add to
look back and are like mortified and
you're like is this what I'm like no
there's sometimes when I'm mortified
where I'm just fat is really all it is
personality but most of the time like
what you realize is that like the more
things change the more they stay the
same right I'm joking are you like
nervous I am there I'm nervous like I
don't get nervous and like I don't know
why like I just feel like there's like
new people watching this show like in
the studio like I don't know them and
like I'm just feeling nervous I'm
nervous like I have cellulite that I
don't know which way it's coming out of
right and honestly like sitting in a
position like this in a short dress like
I'm just not I'm not one of those girls
like some girls survive for like a short
couch with like a dress on like I'm just
not her like you know I'm a bunch of
deer there like that I want to try it's
like sitting hold on I know I know what
you're gonna do I'm gonna put my legs
back okay everyone say a small prayer
she's gonna move is she showing her
vision Oh cute that's cute
does she look good or do I look like I
have a peg leg I like it I like it well
how does it look hi Sandra can you talk
we're talking to you okay okay but like
excuse me what leg is the one like I
have skinny um no but I need to use it
oh my god this is so dumb you guys me
machine you're wasting precious daylight
let's jump into the past five stories
that you got it now you just gotta
before you wake up and take a bite out
of your morning toast
oh okay first story it's the story
everyone's talking about it's really the
fast one story of the week Joe Giudice
lost more than 50 pounds during his
prison stint he has been released
he has been deported it's all so crazy
and if you've seen the pictures it's
even crazier that's yeah it's like the
news of him getting deported is nothing
because we saw this coming but what we
didn't see was a 50 pound weight loss oh
my god it's so crazy a lot of people are
making comparisons that he looks like
Mike the situation which I definitely
see he's like an older older Mike um I
just I saw a picture of him and I was
shook and then I was like maybe it's
just like a weird picture and then gia
Giudice put up a picture of her
facetiming her dad and he looked even
crazier and I'm like who is this you
it's not even like when people lose
weight they look different but like he
has a brand-new fotch he has a brand-new
fatch it's shucking it really is it's
two different people it's weird to see
yeah and I guess I never thought of him
to be like a an out-of-shape person I
just always thought he was like he was
stout like some people just built that
way like yeah Jason oh I did big
but it was like hard you know it like
wasn't soft it was like made of salami
is made of appreciative yeah so I didn't
ever thought like I thought it was like
boldly and like in shape you could never
say that about a woman no you can't but
it's fine
we were oppressing belly Maiden free
shoot so I just find this whole scenario
like to be so shocking and they're all
posting a lot on social media Gia's
posting Teresa's posting but they seem
I'm like seeing their instagrams and
then I'm seeing like conflicting you
know stories in the press about how
they're devastated and like a running
back to Italy to find him but then it's
like Teresa took the kids like a
waterpark you know yeah I mean I'm sure
it's conflicting for them like how do
they handle it like do you stop your
life and go back I don't know they hide
on their dad and so long I don't think
that you do and they've had a lot of
time to grapple with this decision maybe
they have a plan in place right and they
are being like sort of public about it
like Gia posting that photos yeah I
think they have a plan of action and is
it confirmed he's been deported and he's
not allowed back or he just has to go to
Italy while his case is in limbo oh I
don't know I mean the pictures of him
because they were being taken in Italy
yeah so he's definitely there I don't
know if he has to stay there also this
reminds me that when we got off the
plane and lax right in the jet bridge
there was two ice officers like standing
there and if like they were like waiting
to depart someone like I look and
something about it was making me so sad
no it was really crazy I know and they
look just so scary I was like afraid
yeah they were back to snatch snatch it
up it was really sad I couldn't
something about a justice anyway back to
Joe Giudice like is this the saddest
thing the world no but like it is sad
that like they don't have their dad and
like he paid his time for his crime and
it should be enough but it's not it's
looking very hot button issue also like
people are on others either sides and
it's like it's turning into like a
political conversation as everything
does about just like jail time yeah yeah
and the crims nation in the criminal
justice system right speaking up did you
watch Kim Kardashian's Hollywood story
no I had all these big plans of things
to watch like yesterday when I was
struck down and all I could watch was um
inside of your eyelids Talladega Nights
with Ricky Bobby I [ __ ] love that
movie have you seen it legible Ricky
Bobby it's with Will Ferrell where
people I know what it is we're never
ladies an overzealous NASCAR driver I've
never seen it oh my god it's incredible
and our girl Leslie Bibb isn't it Sam
Rockwell's yes actually I'm also also
Amy Adams you know the movie
she got a start you know the the Kanye
song Blanc in Paris mm-hmm
there's this part in the in the song
it's like he doesn't know what that
means nobody knows what it means but
it's provocative and Ben was watching
Ricky Bobby and it's from that movie he
like took a snippet it's kind of how
like Taylor Swift in the beginning of
London boy has Idris Elba's saying on my
school ah oh wow he took like a little
piece and put it in the middle of the
song which I thought was interesting
that is quite interesting anyway so no I
didn't want to Kim Kardashian I didn't
watch a nexium I also need to watch
Jeffrey star I'm getting everyone on the
shane dawson jeffrey start what i have
it all downloaded it's so good I cannot
believe how rich every star is I'm so
jealous like he lives in the same gated
community as all the Kardashians Wow
yeah and they've got he's like that's a
real motivation there yeah you know it's
like I want to work as hard as Jeffrey
star so I can live near the Kardashian
and honestly Jeffrey stars boyfriend
Nate is so hot and like the he doesn't
really like get involved in the series
but he pops in every now and then and he
like obviously is very invested in like
his boyfriend's business because he
knows so much about like colour
swatching and like makeup pilots and
like formulas and she's like really
endearing it like makes him really hot
he's very good-looking that's super cute
I'm like I'm like a big fan even though
when it comes like the whole James
Charles like Tati thing I was like
really not on jeffree star side but it
that's part of like being a YouTube
stand it's like you never know where to
go yeah but I think that's just fine in
general and I think honestly your
biggest cross to bear which I hate to
remind you of but this is like whether
it all comes to is like Kim versus
Taylor oh I like love someone and don't
know where you stand on the conflict
very much Kim vs. Taylor like on my
grade stone it will be Mike this is what
took her down yeah cause of death
Kimber's Taylor it's so true and it
changed the trajectory of her career
forever yeah and I'm the person she is
of your career so true you know and I
will always be your cross to bear thanks
for rubbing it in that's that's like the
origin story of your across to me right
right James verse Jeffrey's just a
symptom yeah of not being able to make
your mind up on Kimber's Taylor and
that's the thing I feel like in today's
day and age we're conditioned to like
choose a side and cancel culture and
it's like why why do I have to right and
it's like I wasn't there I choose not to
choose I choose not to choose okay we
got to speed things along praying for
the Giudice family we are um but I'm
actually like really happy for him that
he lost 50 pounds because he looks great
and that seems like a very like very
small silver lining yeah okay next story
is um
Bachelorette alum Mike Johnson asks keke
palmer on a date after demi lovato think
fling but they could also be called the
cringe eeeh story I've ever read it
could be called Mike Johnson should
never be allowed on a talk show let
alone GMA ever again because he totally
abused his time there and used it to ask
um you keke palmer on a date who was the
new host I think we spoke about this on
the show already that about how she
joins Strahan and Sarah like full-time
which I think was an interesting choice
um in a good way and so basically
they're just like talking and all of a
sudden he just like asked Hickey Palmer
out she was so shocked it obviously was
not planned it was incredibly
uncomfortable I'm now like officially
like dislike Mike Johnson I think it was
one of the weirdest thirstiest like
loser is things to do it was it was a
church yes thank you it's a perfect word
it was vile
and what's craziest is that like Kiki
was obviously like such a gracious Queen
about it because she's a gracious but
she was not interesante no that's that's
the best part it's like you put yourself
out there in the most thirstiest way
only to be completely shut down yeah and
of course she was like so gracious where
she didn't even say no I'm not
interested she was like Mike's like I'm
working yeah but it's also like [ __ ]
I'm working is this not sexual
harassment in the work it was just going
out on a date I would love to hear the
toasters opinions like weigh in on where
does this cross a line and by the way
you have to watch a video because at
first I was only gonna hear the headline
and the story but you can't even read
what was said because basically
everyone's just laughing and cringing
you have to feel the awkwardness you
have to feel the awkwardness from for
yourself
and once again goes to show that he was
not fit to be the bachelor yeah he's
clearly not dating Demi Lovato because
he's asking other women out on national
television and I think Tammy Lovato was
probably really turned off to the fact
that like he was out here telling
everyone that they kiss and that she's a
good kisser well the conversation
started with him saying I made a mistake
I don't like dating in public but if I
were to ask you if we could go on a date
in public that guy so it's like you made
the mistake and Here I am again
by the way so in your opinion does this
cross a line when in terms of
inappropriate behavior okay totally
right here let's put it this way say we
had a guest on our show and one of us
like was single and not married then
someone asked us out like on our show
and like the chance maybe it was someone
you wanted to ask you out so you'd be
excited but like say was someone you
didn't think of and now you're put on
the spot on your own show and what are
you gonna be like rude I don't know I'm
like so abrasive that like I wouldn't
wouldn't feel like I was being harassed
but just like keke palmer zappy job and
like i just felt like she was
uncomfortable like it's not like it's
not as aggressive as harassment but its
discomfort ya know it's inappropriate
workplace behavior like what are they
all over this workplace misconduct I
wonder if there's like any kind of
outrage about it I haven't seen any but
I've also been offline because when you
have food poisoning you also can't look
at your phone
I'd love keke palmer and you know I
really like about keke palmer now that I
think about it is that she's gone so far
and she doesn't like use the tactic of
like dating a celebrity to like even you
know like expand her career even more
like even if she did go on a team with
Mike Johnson like she could probably
thirst hit up like get some Instagram
followers like it wouldn't be the worst
thing in the world for her like publicly
but she doesn't do that like she gets
where she gets based on her merits and I
think that's really cool ya know I love
this new phase of her career where she's
just the hostess with the mostess and
where she's getting respect like we've
been we knew like she deserve respect
from the second she walked onto the True
Jackson VP set of course and then that's
where she met since Jackson yeah the P
the president the VP a yes so like I
don't know I really like her I think
this is really disgusting and honestly I
am NOT into my Chun Mike Johnson I'm
trans a nice guy but this is like so out
of touch like in this climate you can be
doing chilling and also like as if
everything he had done until this point
like wasn't cringy enough like his
twitter account his twitter account his
comments on Demi Lovato's Instagram his
telling the world that she's a good
kisser like him being so like you know
what he's he's weird he's weird yeah
yeah I'm just like remembering other
things like that we've read like someone
in the toasters when he's someone in the
toaster said they like eavesdropped on
his date with Demi Lovato and it was
just like weird yeah and and honestly
makes a lot of sense
there was like mass confusion as to why
he wasn't chosen as the bachelor and now
I feel as though there's no confusion no
none whatsoever we doubt we doubted
bachelor nation and to be honest they
were right once again once again oh my
god snatcher wasn't here when we
reported on Peter breaking his face oh
yes not sure about everything and I'm
hearing about it he's making it seem
like it's less and less of a big deal
like he just like legrand look yeah like
Chris Harrison keeps saying like it's a
nothing yeah I know weren't filming they
might not even address it yeah he'll
just say show that let's live to make
like a mountain out of a molehill there
probably will address it like have a
fake ambulance be like well you know
they live for that they really do okay
switching gears I'm about to I'm hit you
with the saddest story I've ever read it
my god I know what it is and like I want
to cry please no because julianne hough
posted this weekend that both of her
[ __ ] precious gems of puppies died on
the same day and at first it was
confusing because they're like three
years apart we were like maybe they were
soul mates and one couldn't live with
have the other and they both died that
does happen like when you when you have
two dogs and one passes away and they've
been living together for so long the
dog's stomach can flip and it can like
it's basically like dying of a broken
heart which is like the saddest concept
of all time yeah it's also like what
happened in the notebook like Ali dies
right and Noah dies next to her and also
those are the same names of the people
from the affair just something to think
about
Wow well that is such an interesting
point Jackie's now like starting the
affair she'd never watch it that is
garbage don't waste their time great
point
Ali is the mistress and Noah is the
husband yeah that's right interesting
very anyways but then Brooks Laich her
husband took to his Instagram where he
geotag the photo as dog heaven as if it
wasn't like sad enough and he said that
there was a tragedy that happened so
something happened where both the dogs
died I was reading a rumor unfounded
completely but makes sense that it was a
coyote that got both of them yeah but
either way it's the saddest thing I ever
heard her dogs were so [ __ ] cute her
I was like who all of us Cavaliere dog
moms like looked up to mm-hmm and she
wrote a caption that like if I read the
whole thing I'll probably start I don't
it's so sad if you want to go check it
out like and like put yourself through
that kind of pain like feel free to go
for it but it was so beautiful it was
beautiful
I hope these dogs are just like over
that rainbow and just like chillin and
doggy heaven like I hope they're happy
like the whole sponsor the whole concept
of dogs dying might be one of the
saddest things and like it's just like
where do dogs go you know yeah and like
I always think about how I sometimes
wish I never got a dog because I'm going
to have to take it obviously like one
day like put up like go through that and
like why wouldn't Instagram why would
anyone put themselves through that yeah
but it's like because of all the love
that you got every single day and like
it's tough I don't know and I wonder if
like all dogs it always we could say
that about life like why do we bother
continuing on when the end result is
just death why have the children well
because your children are supposed to
outlive you yeah you know carry on
but it's like what's the point I don't
know man I know I just wonder if all
dogs they would like to think about any
eventual death of their dogs because
that's literally what plagues my mind at
night like I cried about I cried before
bed every night thinking about like Theo
dying oh my god I want it like just
saying the word Theo dying like I want
to talk except he's gonna live forever
I know he is actually though he drank
from the Tuck Everlasting fountain
do you remember Tuck Everlasting I can
do I think about that fountain all the
time give me to like would you really
believe in Twilight um at the end of the
day no because then I would be like a
freak really doesn't aid right and then
I've been like you have to languor and
like life is good but like it's
exhausting life is hard
yeah life hopefully for most of us is
long yeah I'm good I'm good and I want
to like experience you know the aging
all the stages yeah and like where I
remember reading that book in an
elementary school and just being like I
wanna drink from the fat and yeah and
now I think about it's like no and if I
was like I would drink from it a few
years ago but now I have these crow's
feet and sorry I don't need I don't need
to keep them and I just want to get more
so I can get Botox so Alexis Bledel was
the girl right and who was tough um you
know who it was mr. Callaghan excuse me
mr. Callaghan oh my god Victor guard
burger guard what is in Tuck Everlasting
I'm ninety nine point nine years old
didn't play her love interest oh no not
her love interest but I think he played
the dad who played der Garber opposite
Alexis Liddell that movie really
launched Alexis play tells career and
she looked so beautiful angelic I know I
don't even really remember the premise
obviously I know that like they drink
and later series pretty much just
Twilight yeah the guy was Jonathan
Jackson well he went nowhere nowhere
Joshua Jackson Jonathan Jackson yeah I
don't know him I don't know her either
would we know him more go she's Avery oh
my god from Nashville
oh my god who's Avery uh he was he
eventually ends up spoiler art with
Juliet but he was dating Scarlett in the
beginning and he was her mean boyfriend
weight mean boyfriend I thought she had
the Nikon era no she had Avery first who
like who was mean to her and then he
like slept with someone and he was like
he was out of control he like had a band
and he was nuts he had to work on his
art no one was really out of control
Scarlett she was worth character
Nashville 100% like she on
in the real world of naturally she never
was gotten anywhere she was too goddamn
annoying ya know and you know what in
Nashville she didn't go anywhere
totally my leg up Botox did it start
working yet you are my brows meeting up
a little coin slot happen action buck
but it's good though it's natural yeah
yeah because you know I'm a comedian I
got to be expressive yeah I was thinking
about almost not getting Botox
no don't yeah but it wasn't worth it
like my show my show is good enough that
I actually was I happened upon some of
my old snapchats from like three years
ago where I used to just talk AB nauseam
about nothing and be really expressive
and my forehead was out of control I
think I got the bad forehead wrinkles
from snapchat from like having something
to say all the time and also like when
you are sitting literally on the edge
edge edge of the campus I'm trying not
to get the son of mine I switched up to
the middle lighthouse she's gonna move
to the middle you guys we're gonna get
this right yes just like I'm sorry it's
la man it's you know it's a really a
blessing and a curse this LA light
because yeah it's there when you need it
so much better
snatcher says so much better okay um by
the way we were talking about Julian
have stalks like we went on an
incredible tangent here about Tuck
Everlasting I wish that CEO could drink
from the Tuck Everlasting pond but then
one day times would hi and he would have
to live without you yeah which I think
he could do he's very much like a love
the one you're with kind and in my in my
old age I in my will it would be like
okay Theo is gonna live with yes nature
I guess he could be like your dog for
like all of your descendants yeah I
guess but maybe like when you go to
heaven like you see your dead dogs maybe
that sounds better that literally sounds
like the definition of heaven yeah like
being like I would be up there with like
daddy grandma grandma and yeah Theodore
for coming also now that I think about
it the movie age of Adaline is like Tuck
Everlasting with dogs
age of Adaline was actually a great
movie yeah except when she loses all
those Cavaliers
yeah but it was like a weird film like
the way it was marketed and I mean
everything she does is weird yeah right
she's in so many fake movies the movie
remember the one end like the whole
billboard is like her stranded on the
wrong we and what about the one she
deleted her whole Instagram for with
Anakin
that went nowhere her name was Emily or
something yeah like where's Emily yeah
yeah yeah yeah like why weird marketing
it's so weird
you take fake movies it's like if it's
like when people make restaurant so that
they could like you know like as a front
these movies are muttering yeah yeah are
fronts yeah just it's a front for the
fact they want to try and prove like
she's not locked up in a cage when we
know she is Ryan Reynolds swallowed and
it swallowed the case our next story is
just like a fun one about two things
that we love Tim Tebow and the keto diet
because Tim Tebow has been on the keto
diet since 2012 Cuomo
I miss my mom's cooking what Tim Tebow
says he's one of the original pants of
the keto diet right after Ben saw her
former NFL player tells people that when
he tried the carb cutting diet seven
years ago he didn't know a single other
person that was on it quote I was the
first person I knew in the beginning of
2012 to do it back when it was just
called Atkins like right like it's
always there not very crazy low carb
it's not like it's not new can I just
tell you that um you were holding your
iPad upside down and like I'm sure it
was fine for you but you looks like one
of those girls who like reads a book
upside you can't even make sure it's for
like they're trying to sneak like spy on
someone so they're like reading of faith
no but in my screen rotated yeah sure
I'm sure I think you were reading the
story it's like um it's like in the
House Bunny when she's like with the
menu exactly cuz I'm not that hungry oh
my God he's an Austin Powers fan he says
quote you learned carbs are the enemy
Tebow explains but admits that there is
one special meal of his mother's that he
misses most it was something called
pizza pie I'm Pete survived yeah I don't
think that's your mom's exclusive Tim it
was made with this crusty huge dough on
the outside we had to switch the crust
find new alternatives somewhere that
sounds awful like you can cheat every
now and then I want to talk about Tim
Tebow I would I mean I want to talk
about Tim Tebow every day and the
weirdest trajectory of anyone's career
like ever like
when I first heard Tim Tebow's name he
was like gone viral because he prayed
every time like a touchdown happened or
something like people in Li yet people
were like living for his precious vibes
and I totally was here for it and he was
turned out to be like so handsome every
celebrity wanted to date him he was
going to every event and then some he's
a virgin
we're oh right he was so interesting and
then something happened where he fell
off the face of the earth and nobody
ever cared about him again and now he's
almost like regarded as a universal
loser you know who that happened to also
who Caitlyn Jenner yes I mean she was a
pioneer until she wasn't it's the
craziest thing she ever pioneer to like
an actual yeah and we're like everyone
was so interested that you could pay
millions of dollars for a proper Otzi
photo of her like she was at she was at
pride in New York she was at a club and
it was like the biggest deal ever a PhD
do you remember one day everyone decided
they just didn't care about her knee no
not only that that they [ __ ] hated
her like didn't team up people don't
care anymore like yes people [ __ ]
hate me there was a moment where people
like I think Caitlyn I think people
hated Tim Tebow and now it's just
indifferent yeah
that's almost worse like as a famous
person percent um but do you remember
when before Caitlyn Jenner actually came
out as transgender like there was a
helicopter paparazzi picture of her on
her Malibu like deck wearing a dress a
black of my dress yeah a white stripe
Jess and then it was like on the cover
of The Daily News New York Post like
that was so crazy that was so crazy and
honestly there's something like that
nobody really talks about incredibly
immoral about that like technically
outing someone no 100% I think after the
Dianne sway our special everyone in the
world like including myself like felt
drive something on my face no I'm I
think I'm breaking out in hives
we quit so [ __ ] edgy oh maybe a
ginger shot you know I [ __ ] hate LA
okay okay well we have a few more days
here so yeah I know hold it down no more
ginger shots for me it certainly wasn't
the McDonald's I think that Caitlyn
Jenner's Diane Sawyer special really
changed a lot of the way that people
talk about other people yeah and it was
like gossip he was like hugely
transformative it's like how you know
minutes decades happen in minutes
minutes happened in decades or whatever
like it takes it takes so much time for
something to change but then once it
does it happens overnight
yeah that's how I feel yeah well Tim
Tebow is what is what we were trying to
say yes are you ready for a fifth and
final story because so fast I just
really want to talk to Gary and Brad I
have so many questions the toaster has
got so many questions for them Gary's
here I'm Gary brad is here you look so
cute
he get it together for the interview I
would let yes preaching I have busy
things to do did the final story police
in Japan arrest pop stars stalker after
he analyzed her selfie and used to the
reflections in her eyes to find her
address what it's like literally an
episode of Black Mirror they arrested a
pop star stalker the pop star found her
address by refusing what was reflected
in her eyes in her selfies that's so
freaky he's got naughty so crazy I meant
now you have to edit all your pictures
to blur out your people's oh my god a
man arrested on suspicion of where was
this in Japan
yeah people in America are that smart
yet no but now there a man arrested on
suspicion of stalking a female pop idol
used the reflections of her pupils in
photos she shared on social media and
Google Streetview to find where she
lived
Tokyo police declined to comment on the
specifics of the investigation but
confirmed Friday the 26 year old Hibiki
SATA was arrested September 17th on
suspicion of indecent behavior in
connection with stalking and causing
injuries to the 20 year old woman the
police official who spoke on condition
of anonymity is often as is often policy
at Japanese okay and also it's like you
can try as you want to like hide you
where you live and like post not in real
time like someone's coming to your house
like that's a lesson like someone is
always on their way to your house that
is just so crazy I mean now I have to
edit my people's great great I mean I
edit everything lesson for all
celebrities but like holy smokes yeah
Jojo so hear about that kpop star who
look very suspicious yeah yeah very
weird very sick behaving world is very
like Scientology vibes I feel like
there's so much that goes on that like
nobody talks about you I feel like they
talk about it but I guess we it was just
very fatty not person who like recently
passed away she was 25 like you don't
just die when you're 25 no which is why
like we'll keep tabs on the story yeah I
just always like to close the book on
those things yeah you know like when we
were even talking about um the one
Directioners sister yeah right when
there was like a week when 18 year olds
were just like dropping dead yeah it's
just nice like to know what what causes
these things that you know you yourself
can prevent it if possible
okay the freaky world we live in I am so
excited we are gonna bring out a Brad
Goreski and Gary Jannetty power couple
tons of questions we got for them on our
answer
I'm the morning doesn't scram obviously
you know you got to follow it we will be
right back and we're gonna be back with
a brad and Gary
we are back with two people we have
gotten so many requests for on the show
I am honored humbled and just off yeah
it's really I mean aw thank you guys so
much for being here
power couple guys can I curse yeah I
know it's okay so you guys are literally
my favorite couple you guys are so like
you're like a great Instagram couple but
not in an annoying way and that's not
what you set out to do do you know name
Ian yeah I definitely did not set out to
annoy yeah like you guys have just so
much stick on your Instagram that is so
organic that I just live to watch I
didn't think I would ever really care
about someone eating linguine but but
it's everything are you shocked at how
people are like so taken by his
Instagram stories of you being a critic
and then also your whole Starbucks order
like you are really like a foodie yeah
here's my Starbucks are now that cuz
you're right up where there's a store
look right below where we're filming you
have your own drink at Starbucks
unofficially unofficially yeah this is
it yeah it's a grande iced cafe mocha
with almond milk only two pumps of mocha
and no whipped cream it's technically
vegan is that right yeah good how many
of those one this though I will tell you
it's my second I will not finish it I
will just have a few sips of it it'll
just it's giving me a little more
personality it's something to kind of
you know it's my cigarette it's your
jewel it's your joy right
one man's cocaine scary so you just
heard about yeah I did do you mind if I
cancel we release I cancel such a great
name for a bug thank you
can you talk a little bit about the
inspiration behind that yeah it's just
their autobiographical essays things
from my childhood
from the time some like come around
eight till about 28 or something like
that the point of you know of my life I
was gonna say your life but the only is
my life where you're kind of figuring
[ __ ] out yeah you know and I
while to actually figure stuff out how
things work like that but um are you
always always seeing style are you
always being styled by your husband no I
just no not usually grad you pick up
carries clothes never know you know I
know I have I actually when we first
started going out eighteen years ago was
actually styled him really yeah I did I
mean a little not not I mean he always
had fashion style and was interested but
I was kind of I guided you know him a
little bit like hey why don't we kind of
you know elevate this little I can go
back to the book now I person to write a
book a person I don't well took me about
it seven months seven months yeah I
didn't know either when I set out I had
never written one before so I was like
and I had a meeting with James Miglia
who's my editor at Flatiron books who's
a fabulous he's this you know he was so
young I was like oh like people are
there you already came in there you know
and we met basically he was from
Instagram Wow you know that they kind of
approached me through GM through know
through my agent but it but it was from
my my kind of thank you for when it was
starting to kind of get really big and
so I was like well this is what I would
want to write a book about so this is
what I'll do and this is how I'll do it
you know and I mean and he's like great
so then you know I got a book deal and I
was like I don't really know how to
write a book deal and then you got to
write that oh I should have opened my
big mouth actually write it but yeah for
me I just sit and started it and thought
let's just see you know where this goes
yeah and kind of what it wants to be and
it was it ended up being something that
I feel really good about putting out
there but you know when you're writing
about yourself it also makes you
vulnerable in a way that I'm not when
I'm doing Prince George or went up
riding for Stewie or for Cameron you
know on Will & Grace it's like you know
it's it's there's a something between
you and
what you're putting out there so you're
a bit protected but when you're writing
about yourself you know you're super
vulnerable if somebody says like they
don't like it it's like they don't like
you they don't like everything you know
so that's kind of been interesting as
it's about to go out into the world so
most of our followers probably know you
from your Instagram which is so huge and
we'll get there but you have like you
are now having like a second life
because what I didn't even know about
you is that you're the executive
producer of Will & Grace yeah yeah and
you're a writer for a Family Guy family
yeah I still write a family god that is
so crazy huh what like how do you like
your also like a New Age influence or
like it's like you've so many different
careers which do you like better you
know it's kind of well being behind the
scenes for so long it's been kind of fun
sometimes to you know try different
things like when Brad started filming me
on on his Instagram story I I didn't
know he was even filming me a lot at the
beginning he would just post them and I
would get a response and I'm like or I
would see it if you tagged me in it like
uh but I didn't I guess I was a kind of
a good sport about it cuz I could see
where you know where I was going
it just felt like what's the harm I
guess I you know whatever and then when
we were away in Italy and we started he
was filming me a lot more when we were
eating together so then I was kind of
like aware but I was like uh screw it
you know I'll just like I'm not gonna
tell him he can't because you know I'll
just that you know just be normal we
have it but I never expected people to
respond to it in other way like he'd
posted I'd be like people are gonna be
like like leaving you in droves you're
Italy content you are just like you have
a way of being silent but like
judgmental at the same time like what
does he think does he like the pasta or
not it's very interesting you guys are
so cute I can't leave you've been
together for 18 years I know we have you
got married last year right about a year
and a half a year and a half ago on a
boat Yannick Russia you - oh yeah yeah
beautiful for us
yeah can you talk about that like why
like that just how you guys were
together for so long did you always want
to get married no was it just like a you
wing it
we didn't always want to get married you
know what the truth is we hadn't really
talked about it much until marriage
became legal right and then we just
always assumed we would eventually you
know do it but you know when you when
you've been together so long and it's
kind of like if it ain't broke yeah yeah
but but it was important to us I think
to ultimately be like you know people
have fought for this right and we wanted
to be a part of it we always CC
ourselves I mean we are you know we
always saw ourselves as married so yeah
well also we wanted to our families are
both so we're very close with each
other's families I love you know I love
my in-laws and you know my family's
coming for Christmas we do Thanksgiving
with his family we like love our
families and so we just decided to do a
big family vacation over the Christmas
holidays on a cruise ship and we got
married on it and it was just like was
like part of the trip so was like yeah
it was part of the trip but we all got
to spend time together which I normally
wouldn't so named one of the captains of
beauty yeah he was everybody on that we
were got married on Seabourn and they
were so amazing yes o mais OU la the
cruise director Ross we both still
follow on Instagram Ross star Robert
Ross was bad is everything yeah we had a
great time and we got to it yeah spend
time with our families that's such a
good way to do it and we got so many
questions okay Instagram you have to
talk about your Instagram because you
are the royal correspondent that we
deserve have you heard from Kensington
Palace in any component on not a friend
of a friend nothing well not
specifically no no you know they can't
actually acknowledge it it would be
beneath them okay like we're aware of
this thing look they don't even
acknowledge you know any scandal you
can't acknowledge a thing they the Queen
didn't acknowledge when Princess Diana
died you know the whole movie about it
basically yeah it's this sense of you
know you don't engage and in
hi-yah in that way I think so no to
engage in an Instagram account from some
guy from LA hello I've heard through
people that people have seen and people
have liked I somebody told me that they
were at princess Eugenie's wedding and I
was posting the whole day that about
George you know and Eugenie and he
thought she was one of me it was like
the faces he was made but you know I
kind of match what I'm getting with what
you know the situation is and then I
kind of come up with the story from
there
so I somebody reached out to me that
they were at the wedding and he was
sharing it as I was posting at her
wedding with the people I disabled at
her wedding some loving thought also
things outrageous that you're doing this
at the wedding but I so that was kind of
funny to find out oh that's crazy
I can't believe how big your Instagram
it's like I remember when you had like
$30,000 and now you're reaching a
million you were early I was an early
adapter you were very early I had only
been posting about of Moscow and I was
before George you yeah right you used to
pose just like black bags and there's so
much I still do occasionally George
really barreled his way okay this is
from Ali Weinreb for Brad who has been
your favorite celebrity to style you
style everyone who's cool oh do you
think is like the most fun to work with
and like most willing to take risks oh
my god
I am lucky you know if you my clients
are always on my Instagram so it's like
a party with all of them it looks so
much fun I mean they're all great like I
danced with Jenna I laugh with Leanne
Kaylee and Sarah you know I work with
great women that you know are super
funny and make my job really really easy
so it's hard to pick one because we're
always it's like a sleepover you just
have the best time and you also do the
red carpet pre-show a lab is that that
looks like so much work like they eat I
live oh you too you yeah I love it so
much I love you in your shorts but like
a full tuxedo on top you know
I'm not playing around yes G I've been
doing this for a while so I you know
it's always really hot on the Emmys and
I just said to you know that my my
friends at E before we went live I was
like do you mind if I don't wear pants
and I just wear my gym shorts they're
like no this is the first year without
the see-through table so I took
advantage of it
oh I didn't realize the tables always
see-through that's a good point yeah
people worked in our I worked in our
favor
also for Brad from Parker Hill I've been
feeling bored of my fashion choices what
advice do you have to freshen up your
look slash style and bring in a new edge
I say gently dip your toe into trends
through accessories um if you don't want
to take the big you know the big plunge
and we're like all animal print or we're
all neon or brocade or all of those
things you can incorporate those through
your Footwear your clutch your you can
get like a cute little jacket or just
like an animal print shirt and wear it
with jeans I love it yeah I'm sure I
think I need animal print yeah you
definitely need animal print okay you
think are the best Shores for like
affordable pieces like every day I'm a
big online shopper yeah so I shop on
like Amazon I shop on mr. Porter I shop
all over the place but I don't love
being in a store I mean either it's so
much more no I'm like I don't if I can't
find my size like usually when we wake
up in the morning he's reading the New
York Times and I'm like scrolling on
like right shopping yeah yeah so yeah I
shop all over the place Target I just
got an outfit that you thought was
buffalo plaid the black and red pants
I've been wearing I've got those at
Target the other day like I love chaps
you guys
I love a bargain I love a target yeah it
needs to be like 50% off or more we got
a question for you that we were both
dying tonight your opinion because last
week we reported on that youtuber girl
who crashed the Chanel fashion show yeah
and I would love as your take as someone
who's probably been to a Chanel fashion
show what what are your thoughts but I
thought it was amazing yeah did you not
think like it was just so [ __ ] rude
no I thought it was kind of incredible
elaborate come on any time but like
somebody is doing something
to shake up something that's like very
formulaic and taken very seriously yeah
kind of I just thought it was kind of
such a great innocent risk you know and
I thought saying I thought that gigi
hadid also really did a good job in
dealing with it like maintainence
situation yeah because I'm like that's a
pro like that's somebody who you know
she made she let that thing kind of
happen and then very tidally cleaned it
up yeah you know which could have been
like kind of a bigger mess with all
those models walking like she knew how
to deal with that and I you know I think
a lot of people are gonna dress up like
the Chanel show crasher for Halloween oh
that's a great prediction a great
costume was she wearing Chanel good job
of blending in like how do you rate her
outfit her shoes were wedges that's the
shoe the footwear threw me off yeah yeah
but I you know and nobody got hurt and I
think in this day and age when we can
kind of like latter about things I think
it's a big risk that that I think paid
off and I think people were you know
sometimes we need to get like a little
shake and fashion takes itself so
seriously it's the most ridiculous the
thing that should take itself the least
serious yeah when it takes itself the
most serious so the fact that somebody
kind of came in it was playful yeah you
know changing my mind an interesting
spin I did and that was a win-win
situation like nobody got hurt Gigi
looks great we all got to see more of
the Chanel show than we would have
because it wasn't you gonna get hurt big
it's like people can stop walking
but they going right or no traffic
she never nice one of those girls might
have just like pushed her off the right
way Chanel show cracker Gary this is
from Lady Lucia is anyone on will on
great willing grace or any storyline
from whirling grace based loosely on
your life or anything that ever happened
to you
yeah there was one one thing that I
wrote it was Will and Grace went to
Will's mom's house step life down are
playing and grace broke accidentally a
Lladro figurine which is something that
my mother used to keep in her home and
that my sister broke once and it sent
the two of us insane talisman right so
it was this it was based on that the
grace goes into this crazy tailspin
because she breaks wills mom's favorite
favorite Lladro figurine so that was
this very specific story yeah lay it out
in the show and I also love Blythe
Danner so until she was fabulous and
that was exactly from my life that's so
cool that one Gary also appeared on Will
& Grace yes I knew I was wills first
boyfriend in an eighties flashback yes
flashback so it was super fun so when
you were working on willing grace you
guys worked together at the time we were
together yeah together yeah that's so
cute I can't believe you guys just so
much history yeah yeah yeah that's how
you met Madonna tell us about that
it was everything was she everything
yeah I mean she wasn't like she was long
fuzzy she's fine you got your picture
yeah yeah okay I want you to play a game
with me Gary about the Royal children
all right I'm actually know before I do
that actually the questions you ever
feel like you have taken it too far no
your jokes no you haven't
you have it keep going do you think
you're more of a George
or like a Charlotte George Oh for like
you are George yeah do you see yourself
in George you know I see George as a
character like any character that I
would write so he is so there's a there
is a part of myself in every character
that
right you know what I mean so in as far
as that goes yes yeah but he I write him
as this fully like any character on a TV
series but it's so crazy because I know
you like wrote this character but like
it's totally him like you know well
that's like at me I mean that's good
that you think that cuz it's totally
created obviously he's probably the
sweetest six-year-old little kid Brad I
have a question for you and we asked
everyone who comes on our show who knows
Lea Michele this question um there is a
huge conspiracy theory out there and you
either need to confirm or debunk it for
us I'm not sure if you've heard about it
it's that Lea Michele can't read I've
never heard that oh there's so much
there's so much proof did you send her a
copy for your book
yeah I did we'll see if she reads it
yeah she never did well the evidence is
that like she's never actually been seen
like right captions are just emoji emoji
isn't it like Ryan Murphy like likes
working with her and she likes working
with him because he knows great great
and it's got like a few reads the
scripts to her so she can memorize them
no she just post out about the Reese
Witherspoon book club the book from the
book club writing yes everything well
it's not like we sit down by I handle
light with a quill pen light paper and
I'm watching write in her journal that
all of her headshots are like pre-signed
like there's never been a video of her
signing a headshot do you want me to get
her to sign some pie I would if you
could send me a video of just like her
like jotting something down on a first
day on Thursdays all I got hurt well the
conspiracy that's so big that she
actually had to address it I think she
did on watch Robin's live yes it is so
funny
but how would she learn like all of her
parts do you guys also believe that like
you shouldn't get a flu vaccine because
it like puts a microchip in your body
you sick i one year I got the flu what's
a year I got the flu shot yeah because
you're supposed to you they get a little
you get responsible menu I've never
heard about the microchip or not I think
that's no I backed the no no yeah
the next question is would you ever do
another reality show sure yeah why not
what's like your dream reality show like
would it be a you guys show would it be
like a work styling show well I did work
styling so maybe I would do something
with her That's Gary are you open to it
you know I don't know Never Say Never
right promote the book yeah he's gotta
go on book tour first right where are
you I'm going to New York I'll be in New
York October twenty seconds on the
fourth side then Brooklyn the 23rd yeah
Manhattan Brooklyn Toronto cool Portland
International what are you gonna do on
tour like a little reading very I'm
gonna read an essay from my book and
I'll I guess I'll you know meet anybody
wants to meet me whatever turns us yeah
we'll see who turns up right yeah that's
so fun
yeah I hope people come do you think the
book it sounds great yeah oh thanks I
love it you know so not too long things
to do yeah I'm reading Howard Stern's
book it's like five hundred texts but
it's a text book I can't even travel
with it because it like it's too big so
heavy it's like traveling with the
September module miles yeah you can
knock it out in a few days um this is
from sim Marinelli Brad can you please
talk about your relationship with Tanya
rad who's coming on the show tomorrow
yeah he told me and are we gonna get
another beer at tier at dancing video
yes you will when is it gonna be to
toast by claudius right oh yeah oh my
god I would die like seriously died she
actually sent it to me as a potential
yeah it's true i choreographed it we do
it together yeah she comes in with some
ideas and then we try to like mesh them
together but we've had like three failed
attempts at at coming up with some good
choreography so we kind of put them two
for a minute but I I'm seeing her
tomorrow as well so I have to like pitch
to her that maybe we do like a Halloween
theme song I thought Jojo see it see
what did a great one oh really she's
like Julie rave would you ever would you
ever style Jojo see wha
sure yeah Beau's everywhere I know I
know the guy that makes C is beau so I
could just go there
Jojo C good right there out of space
case Brad is there a celebrity you
haven't worked with that you would kill
to Jennifer Lawrence oh that's a really
great answer yeah Kyle sir my friends
Jill and Jordan we're happy for them
we're so happy for them but I just feel
like like in my fittings with like Leah
we can talk about housewives non-stop
and I feel like I could do the same with
Jennifer Lawrence 100% right guys this
favorite housewives do you watch Gary at
least everybody knows your favorite Lisa
Rinna and Erica Jane meet you there
honestly part of my top five overall
franchise I think they're both stars
I love Bethany to live how are you
feeling about her absence yeah I feel
like the shows not any more I think it's
actually gonna be like really terrible
yeah like I'm not one to be like
doomsday but it's just she's the only
one with like a firm grasp on reality on
that and now everyone's gonna get away
with everything like LuAnn is never
coming back down to her yeah because no
God yeah that's true but like there's
just no accountability they need to tell
it right why would earth but I like that
they'll get new people and kind of yeah
up although but I feel like Bethany yeah
I'll totally but I feel like Dorinda and
Sonja kind of bring it to yeah I'm not
like crazy about you Randa I know
there's like I know helium he she's like
universally loved and like I never
really got it cuz anytime I'd watch her
in the past five years she's like always
on the wrong side of history you know I
never agreed with her except this season
she finally like crawled up Bethenny's
ass a little bit which is where you
gotta be everyone the child be so far up
her ass like I'd be coming out of her
mouth everything she does is right you
know and she's so smart everything she
does is right she's saving the world how
you could disagree with her is beyond me
yeah I think do you think she'll come
back to TV in another class she's
working with Mark Burnett they're doing
reality set together yeah she's she's a
smokey yeah yeah yeah also the did you
notice that the Skinnygirl brand keeps
like she doesn't really like drop the
product hard now but like on her story
she'll be like so hungry Skinnygirl
ranch dressing just drop its organic
world yeah yeah
Skinnygirl popcorn is the best yeah the
snack she's always snacking on I'm like
oh they have licorice now yeah they do
watch Orange County yeah yeah yeah I
just thought some Broadman I love bra
I'm actually doing watch what happens
live next week I think I'm gonna be with
Bronwyn oh my that's so cool have you
done watch happens live before yes what
have you been on trappings like before
yeah you have times one have you Gary
I'm Brad yes it was great it was fun
oh my god yeah we did it together oh you
did that's reality show oh right
Kyle Richards what are you so you like
Bronwyn
yeah like borrowing a lot interesting
yeah yeah what do you like about her I
think I like her family they seem kind
of really lovely and fits her so sweet
the family seems kind of nice I like her
I just feel like she brings us there's a
sweetness to heart that comes out on the
show yeah and I think she brings a sweet
energy to the show that actually goes
nicely with some of the other way yeah
like yeah yeah yeah the first season
yeah I like the yeah I think she's
charming and she's kind of got a
different thing and yeah and she's super
pretty and and her kids are respectful
which is like very much watched Alice no
no only two we don't want Potomac you
gotta get into I just got into it it's
really it's phenomenal and like we know
what's going on no it's so good I just
got into it and like the cultural
implications of the show are so crazy
because gizelle is now she was divorced
but getting back together with her
husband Jamal Bryan who's like the sujin
civil rights activist and they just did
a Sunday service with Kim Kardashian at
his church like there's just so I'm an
yeah
so like important it's just a good show
I don't all right yeah wait did they
just wrap up a seat yeah so you got away
all right okay and then there's like a
whole sexual when they're you when it
suddenly it'll get six episodes and that
you know you can't one flight on JetBlue
to New York are you guys JetBlue mint
people yeah
is that your go-to from LA to New York
usually really yeah who are you
delta-1 really yeah we're obsessed with
Delta right now we celebrities
everywhere they be serviced yes and they
have like that LAX they have the special
place you could like go in this crazy
thing we're so bothered is there a star
above are at the terminal I want to say
you were Oh in LA in no and you know
what else there isn't I went to that
terminal once and I went to every single
store and there was not a single tampon
tampon where is Gloria Steinem like it
was an abomination
really you believe that three separate
stores are going on carry tampons I'm
like it was like a Hudson news like you
don't carry tampon it's Hudson news and
it they do I get aspirin there yeah I
wouldn't be here to ask what did you do
[Laughter]
it comes out October 22nd to OB from and
it's available everywhere Amazon its you
can order it pre-order on Amazon order
on Amazon and it's kind of it's out
everywhere in bookstores everybody's
been asking me because I've been posting
yeah I mean the audience he reads the
audiobook so if you buy the audiobook
Gary will be what was that like sitting
in the studio reading your own book yeah
I kind of enjoyed that part yeah you
know it's hard to read constantly
without flipping any little tiny error
you know and having to go back it's gets
tiring ah yes like oh you know and
suddenly words start looking like
nonsense yeah like is that a word you
sit in a comfortable chair yeah yeah to
me that would be important yeah people
do it like a stool yeah yeah carries you
know I talk very fast I don't talk as
fast as you I know it's not a very
impressive thank you because I get that
I talk fast a lot that I have to slow
down I'm saying some when I'm reading it
I tend to talk faster than I can
actually read well thank you so yeah
and I'm like I'm going so slow usually
they're like you're not right now you
need to read it so people can understand
it now I understand perfectly perfectly
thank you I love a talk fast a fast
talker and where can people find out
more information about the book tour if
they want to come my instagram at gary
Jannetty my i have it on there and you
should just be following your Instagram
regardless because so premium content
all that congratulations on the book
thank you guys so much for coming here
we love you the toasters Lobby they were
very excited and we will see you guys
tomorrow with Tonya rad bye guys have a
good day